M Night Shyamalan the living embodiments
of the phrase It's either hit or miss
has made a new film let's talk about
that
so knock at the cabin like I said it's a
new M Night Shyamalan film there's this
couple they're staying at this cabin
with their daughter and then four people
who apparently watched way too much
Blues Brothers were like we're on a
mission from God so to give this family
this ultimatum one of you needs to die
or else the apocalypse is gonna happen
that's it it's very simple that's what I
like about a good Shyamalan film a
character based film simple keep it in
the pocket just have it Thrive off of
tension and Intrigue and here we go now
Dave Batista is the biggest star in the
film so I'm gonna go ahead and start out
with him also he's the leader of these
four folks I mean obviously just look at
him like who's the leader I'm gonna go
ahead and say Alpha Batista right there
was anyone gonna challenge him anyone
gonna want to fight him for leadership
no it's not gonna happen I thought
everyone in the film did a great job but
Batista continues to impress me dude was
a movie star after Guardians of the
Galaxy no doubt but it was Blade Runner
2049 Rob was like that's not just a
movie star he's an actor he could have
rested on The Laurels of that [__] you
Guardians of the Galaxy money but he
didn't was like I want to expand refine
my craft be an artist I love that I
respect him for that this is one of the
more relevant timely films in terms of
social constructs of today the
shyamalan's made part of the Intrigue is
whether or not you're dealing with a
situation that has to do with thought
Bubbles and people online who have the
same mindset maybe they see the same
things and maybe those things aren't
real but to them it's very real if this
actually really appreciate that the film
had some great tension and Intrigue
you're like are these folks Maniacs are
they crazy are they right that's when
the film's at its best when the audience
is wrestling with this you're given
enough information to be like could be
true could be [__] however subtlety
being an art form in a world where
Shyamalan had subtlety sprinkled all
throughout the Sixth Sense yeah he might
have lost the art of that craft
sometimes to the film's detriment
problem with this movie is you have
enough information to go either way
there are these little nuances that you
catch in here details that are supposed
to be vague details the audience is
supposed to pick up on and wrestle with
the situation then the characters and
talking with themselves break down the
details that's supposed to be there for
the audience to catch one small example
of this I'm just going to give you it's
not a spoiler at all it's just an
assessment an assessment that some might
have made from the trailers these four
folks are like hey we need to do this
thing or the apocalypse is gonna happen
there are four of them a cool thing to
glean from the audience is like oh there
are four of them kind of like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse that's a cool
detail then at a point in the movie one
of them says there are four of them it's
likely the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse it's just one example to
illustrate a thing that happens
throughout the film it's like the fear
is the audience won't ever get it it's
not that they won't it's all a matter of
when and again sometimes you want the
audience to grab everything right then
and there even if that means a character
tells the audience exactly what they're
supposed to notice at any given time but
it's a lot more fun if the audience
doesn't get it maybe a month from now a
year from now 10 years from now they're
talking with their friends their friends
bring up a detail or maybe they watch
YouTube videos breaking down the details
and we're like oh I didn't catch that oh
that's awesome I feel like explaining
things breaking things down in cran for
the audience takes an experience from
would-be chess to Checkers I still enjoy
Checkers it's just fundamentally
different than chess and I could have
gone for a more ambiguous film maybe a
nuanced Ending by the end of this film
you have the answers to whether or not
these folks are saving the world from
the apocalypse or they're just batshit
open endings or ending things open to
interpretations true they used to drive
me nuts but I'm at the grumpy old man
energy phase in my life where my brain
has realized that that's kind of how
life works so my brain has learned to
enjoy that thing which used to cause it
pain storytelling Stockholm syndrome but
maybe but it is what it is like in the
end I enjoyed knocking the cabin I know
I feel like I prattled on more about the
thing that bothered me in the film
rather than the things I enjoyed don't
mean for that to be the case just as it
is I feel like negatives require more of
an elaboration than positives this movie
did what it needed to do it had a
mystery Some solid tension you don't
want this family to go through this
choice that they might not even have to
do and this movie has a couple we'll say
logic leaps like logic blind spots that
characters would bring up granted most
any film has moments like that if they
didn't How It Should Have Ended as a
YouTube channel just wouldn't exist but
it is really frustrating as an audience
member when you spot it immediately and
you're like why is nobody in this cabin
bringing this up then you feel
overqualified like you just talk your
way out of the situation among a cabin
full of crazies like I could do that
knowing that you'd be tied up on scared
shitless yourself but still Point
remains I do feel like there is some how
it should have ended low hanging fruit
in this film you know you better than I
know you as I say so my my job here is
to just inform you of that if that's
going to bother you to the point of not
having fun it's probably not your cup of
tea if you can look past you can
probably have yourself a good time that
is to say a good time no alcohol
required for better for worse this is a
Shyamalan film I feel like this film
leans harder into the better than the
worst all right so a knock at the cabin
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
I called it a knock at the cabin it's
it's just knock at the cabin there's no
way
whatever I'm keeping it